this week on couch tomatoes were talking
the mandalorian from Disney Plus and
giving you our fresh picks on what else
to watch on TV hello hello friends
welcome back to couch tomato sponsor
bite for show - pizza I'm your host Nazz
Perez and today on the show we're diving
deep into the first live-action Star
Wars series it's called the baby Yoda
show I'm just kidding it's called the
Mandalorian but we're definitely talking
about baby Yoda later today and here to
help me talk about it is the author of
why we love Star Wars Ken nap sock
colliders Perry Nemiroff and finding
goes film and TV correspondent Niki
Novak hello hello guys I got to tell you
I'm so happy you're here just because
I'm a prequels lover and kid at heart so
I feel like much to learn I have I am
but a young padawan amongst your
presents I love it I actually coined the
term prequel list and we are strong we
are those who look past a lot of silly
things to find the the themes that
George put in there and those themes
they're present in the Mandalorian Wow I
feel like I've just been knighted by
okay guys let's jump right into it in a
galaxy not that far away from our couch
the Mandalorian is set five years after
the events of Return of the Jedi and the
fall of the Galactic Empire and we know
the show follows a lone bounty hunter
known as the Mandalorian now Ken if
you're a fan of the film's we know
Django and Boba as bounty hunters we're
familiar with them but is there anything
about the Mandalorians that we need to
know or should know going into this
that's out there well the first thing
that you should know is Django and Boba
aren't actually Mandalorians they are
accused Django has been accused of
stealing the armor and running around
pretending to be a Mandalorian now that
could turn out to be something totally
different but the culture is was is very
warlike very they love their violence
but then Duchess Satine during the Clone
Wars era believed in peace and started a
movement of peace and that kind of
became the culture so a lot of a lot of
pride and honor and that outfit and
those armor the armors of the mantle arm
that's really interesting because I feel
like most people are just categorizing
the Mandalorian with boba and Jango but
what I love about this show is that the
creator Jon Favreau and the EP de
felonious said that you don't need to be
a Star Wars fan to jump into this and
hop on the bandwagon but what do you
guys what are you guys loving about the
show so far
I couldn't agree more
that statement I mean that's one of my
favorite things about the show to start
is how narrow the focus is I as much as
I love the galaxy far far away and all
the possibilities that are in it the
fact that we have this one main
character and we're getting to I mean
essentially live with him for a little
and experience his day-to-day life I
feel like that's part of the reason the
shows kicked off so strong what I love
about it is that it really does have its
own feel although it's steeped in the
Star Wars universe there's a hundred
thousand esther eggs for people to find
it really does feel like its own thing I
love it it's just kind of unfolding
slowly you know I remember from like the
force awakens you jumped right into the
action this sort of like it takes its
time and you're really getting invested
in the characters I love it and we were
actually talking about earlier how I
love the fact that it's episodic so it
comes out week to week and I just feel
like Star Wars is an event you know we
want to talk about this stuff week to
week and Nicki and I actually sat down
earlier and had the ultimate debate on
whether it's better to binge an entire
series or watch it week to week take a
look
so Nicki today's show got me thinking
about how I like to watch shows do you
like watching one Episode a week like
the good old days or do you like binging
an entire season in one Senate Oh
binging for sure I'm Way too impatient
to wait week to week I love seeing
everything in one sitting how about you
I actually like watching one episode a
week because I feel like it gives me
something to look forward to but I also
love just inviting friends over tossing
in a pizza and then talking about the
episode with that matter makes way more
sense in the way I do it
experience more fun it does and it
doesn't have to be anything formal
whenever they come over I love serving
for shut up pizza because they have so
many different flavors so I'm able to
mix it up and make the episode special
so what are you serving this week and am
I invited you are always invited and
this week I am serving the gluten-free
pepperoni the pepperoni is so good and
zesty and no joke the gluten-free crust
tastes just like regular pizza I want it
now we just have it now let's do okay
all right guys so at the time of this
recording we've all only seen two
episodes so far so if you haven't seen
chapters 1 and 2 of the mandalorian this
is your official spoiler alert
chapter 1 is 88% on the tomato meter 39
minutes long chapter 2 93% on the tomato
meter just a short 32 minutes long which
brings up an interesting question is
Star Wars better in smaller bites or on
the big screen what do you guys think
look Star Wars is an epic event right
even even Bob Iger talks about / - you
know keeping that intact with movies but
the audience is what we want out of
stories now has changed I always look at
shows go back to los sopranos Game of
Thrones is the big example of we we want
to take time and they're forcing us as
fans to take time with these characters
talking about binge or not it's like
they're like no you're gonna have
patience you're gonna enjoy this story
over the course of short little bites
and it's and it's working and I never
thought I'd be saying that as a Star
Wars fan I thought it was really
interesting when I first when the first
episode when I start to press play in
the first minute it's so beautiful and
it has a cinematic feel I felt like oh
my gosh you're poor thing being seen on
this little screen you deserve a big
screen in this cinematic but that's what
I love about it is that it is cinematic
quality but we can take the time and I
mean we just want more Star Wars so I
think whether or not this turns into
then a film adaptation I think it's it's
all good it's all up it's the best time
to be a Star Wars fan for that reason we
get the best of both worlds we still
have films on the way eventually after
rise of Skywalker but now we're gonna
have all of this Disney Plus content to
fill those gaps and the idea of having
these mini stories with the same
character so far approving to be
extremely effective right it gets you
even more excited and we're and us even
a Star Wars fans are learning more sides
to the story that we didn't even know
for example baby Yoda let's talk about
the little green elephant in the room
this thing is so cute like I don't know
if I want to eat it or like punch it in
the face which I did not appreciate that
it's my biggest fear of life so I would
say something there the whole time I'm
like oh is that how it gets its green
color like species Nicki are you afraid
of frogs or eating frogs which is the
bigger fear if you put one on the table
right now I would be out of this world
baby this has been fascinating this is a
the show when in a real interesting
direction to be like oh you thought it
was just gonna be about a Mandalorian
bounty hunter in the underworld Star
Wars no this has ramifications for the
franchise's ramifications for the fame
I really think this is going to lead to
us learning the biggest secret in Star
Wars which is Yoda's species and that's
I didn't expect that in a live-action
star we're focused on other things and
then this pops up and there's a place
for cute and Star Wars yeah there always
needs to be I'm excited to dive into
theories with you guys but before I just
want to know what your initial thought
was when you saw it like was your mind
blown because people are going crazy
mean the Internet's calling it baby Yoda
we obviously don't know if it's even
related to but what were your thoughts
on it when you first thought you never
know though I think the timeline could
kind of work out for it to be related to
Yoda but I remember sitting there
watching that first episode I had big
smile on my face from start to finish
I was absolutely loving it particularly
the stuff at the IG droid towards the
end but what took it from like it - love
it was the second I got that shot that
reveal at the end that this character
exists and the way that they've kind of
upped that character through Episode two
that opens the door to so many
possibilities and I think it's also
possibilities that could not only affect
the show going forward but also maybe
rise Skywalker - yep I think it's the
new baby Groot baby he is the new baby
Groot it says that Universal is there
anybody that doesn't love what we're
calling baby Yoda fur for now but I
think in Episode two what I really
appreciated was seeing that relationship
start to build with the Mandalorian and
how he's this you know slow he's this
warrior stoic character and you know
baby I was giving this these looks and
trying to help him and heal him and he's
just not having any part of it and it's
really intriguing me because I'm what I
love about Star Wars is the
relationships and that relationship to
me it's so intriguing right now I can't
wait to see baby autumn break him down I
know
bring him down well you brought up how
he almost tried to heal him which we
haven't seen the force ever heal someone
so we're only two episodes into you guys
let's talk about theories speculation
and expectation let's start with this
baby yoda thing because Perry you
brought up a good point this could
affect the rise of Skywalker and the way
that this show the way that the episodes
of the Mandalorian is releasing syncs up
perfectly Episode seven comes out the
day before the rise of Skywalker Episode
eight comes out a week after you know is
this baby Yoda
gonna bring balance to the force and
maybe defeat Emperor Palpatine I don't
know if I'm willing to go that far just
yet but the fact that the run of this
show does bleed into that movie I mean
that's kind of what you've got to do
right now to play the game and to battle
all the other franchises out there is
have that connectivity they're doing it
with the Marvel shows on Disney Plus
right it would make sense for them to do
with their Star Wars shows as well and
you know when Raisa Skywalker is
supposedly about finding balance in the
force having a character with force
abilities like this baby Yoda has
already showed us and also being of the
Yoda legacy to some extent whether this
character is actually related to Yoda or
not that does seem to be like that key
that could be missing especially because
when we left these main characters in
last Jedi their forces were greatly
diminished they could use the help and
it seems like baby Oda can be the one to
swoop in and maybe not save the day but
lend a little hand and I was surprised
to see him use the force in episode 2
but let's go down that road what are
your speculation expectations do we
think this is a clone because dr.
Pershing had a clone emblem on his suit
what do we think I am very intrigued by
the clone aspect in the clone angle
thing but Dave Filoni loves putting
stuff in and he's been helping craft
this show with Favreau and I think Dave
likes to just drop things into the
cannon water and be like have fun with
that but the idea is it related to Yoda
is it yeah Dalls did yeah DeLand Yoda
have some they may break some Jedi Code
III all I know is that the theme of a
Mandalorian who's an orphan himself
connecting with this orphan now is going
to lead us somewhere I just don't know
if JJ Abrams and Chris Terrio are
watching that to figure it out or were
aware of it so I'm open to the big
theories do you have any theories Nick I
kind of concur with the two of you I
don't know I think the the cloning thing
is I mean obviously we're all going to
talk about and then it's gonna end up
being yeah sorry I know that's what you
thought I think no we're not going to
make that easy with that easy for you
amino patch is such a big deal though
it's it's just and also because it's not
the only place we've speculate
about possible cloning - it's like you
know the Luke Han the Ray thing that's
been have been a big theory that's been
floating around for quite a while and if
that doctor appeared in the Mandalorian
when he did and had that kind of
conversation and has that kind of
investment in bringing back baby Yoda
alive one would think that he would want
to do what his old facility used to do
and clone a force user I mean it seems
like such an obvious path to me I I I'm
becoming more intrigued with who else is
sending the other bounty owners after
baby Yoda like IG 11 AG 11 the trend
ocean brothers for all I know they all
have a tracker
who else descended it I don't think it's
just the client Warner Hertzog's
character I think there's someone else
there that's where my theory mind is
going
who knows maybe maybe but with Boba
Fett's behind it all just like you know
what I'm I'm still in the game I need
this big score I don't know that that
that's pretty exciting people that's
another theory running in the Internet -
as people say you know Bova died he fell
in the pit but we never actually see him
die is it possible that Boba Fett is the
Mandalorian no I don't think he's the
Mandalorian but I yeah in in modern
Canon in the aftermath novel series by
chuck wendig's you do learn the armor is
there in the Sarlacc pit a character
named Cobb Vance takes it and puts it on
but there was no body so who knows Ken
I'm glad he brought up the aftermath
trilogy so for those of you guys
watching they're a set of novels that
take place between Return of the Jedi
and the force awakens do you think that
they're taking any other source material
from those books and putting it into
this show
III think they're taking the tones and
the themes and the world-building I
think what's going on in this we're five
years after Jedi the New Republic's
trying to figure out what to do Mon
Mothma is trying to demilitarize the New
Republic and that's kind of gonna help
lead the rise of these people looking
for identity this short shows about
identity the Empire needs identity
identity post-fall cara dune is a rebel
soldier who needs an identity without a
war he is a bounty hunter who needs his
identity back as a Mandalorian and I
think that's where some of the bigger
things will come out of the shell
aftermath is a great read for anybody
who hasn't read those books but I don't
know
how much they're pulling from the book
specifically just because they never
really have to a degree as far as new
characters and new information goes but
I don't know I'm semi entertaining the
boba fett idea even though I'd uh
if I had a bet right now I would say no
he's not Boba Fett but there are certain
things out there that do align quite
well the the time period is very very
appropriate so it could the fact that
you know he falls into the Sarlacc pit
the the armor does still exist but even
if it was chewed up he would need new
armor and it does kind of look like we
already saw them replace the shoulder
with the best cars so he does clearly
need new armor so it could have been
because of that event and I heard we
learned more about the best car steel in
the third episode from friends in the
building that have seen it before have
you guys seen the third episode yeah
I've not yet I need I need your friends
well let's talk about other things that
we do know we know that this baby Otis
50 years old can wear would that put it
was this thing born before Phantom
Menace though around that time that the
Star Wars math you're 25 years away from
Revenge of the Sith
which means you're there what do you
know you got about 15 years going back
to Phantom Menace my Star Wars math gets
a little fuzzy yeah I didn't do it well
but it's wrong what about other great
characters have you seen like do we
think IG 11 has gone for gutter we were
talking about that before we were
theorizing I mean you have Taika Waititi
you have one episode instantly the
second he came on screen you're like
need more of this but it's just like
them to say especially tyka and knowing
Tychus personality no we're just gonna
give you a bet I know you want more but
no it's not gonna ever be such a shame
that fight sequence was so good and the
IG droids are just they're so visually
stimulating it's so much fun to watch
them in action maybe we'll get another
IG droid it doesn't have to be IG 11
there are other bounty hunter droids out
there who knows maybe we can get a
different one can I have a selfish
question or two all of you guys are his
eyes like what he shoots out of this
bounty droids I I'm trying to see we're
all learning
it's been right in this series since the
80s he dumped his counter figures on the
floor and said what if what if and
that's where we're finally getting to
see an IG series droid move like we
haven't because in Empire Strikes Back
it's a prop sitting there that's just
you can't move it so the fluid the
movement he has he has some character in
those eyes I'm I wouldn't say no I
wouldn't trust that droid to not shoot
me from his eyes and Carl Weathers his
character grief carga mentions a
smuggler and the way he says the word
smuggler makes me think are we gonna get
a han solo cameo in the Mandalorian what
do you guys think I I would say no at
this point I have a feeling that's not
gonna happen now that I'm saying that
I'm thinking about the like the swell of
support for alden ehrenreich to return
as as solo at some point but I mean it
would kind of make sense because we're
on an outer rim planet and he could be
out in that region but I still think
that it goes back to what we were saying
at the very beginning of this episode
that one of the main benefits that they
have right now is how contain this world
is and how unique it makes it feel while
also maintaining the pillars of what
makes Star Wars Star Wars so I think it
would it would be in their benefit to
play in that little sandbox for a little
while longer
let's talk Easter eggs guys cuz there is
a lot of them in here so what have been
your favorite Easter eggs so far in the
show for me it was the notice and notice
integrations thing which you know Vader
says to Boba Fett and Empire Strikes
Back and you just kind of grow up
imagine imagining what that might be in
your head and even though again not
necessary this is Boba Fett but the
weapon comes from Boba Fett's holiday
special weapon so to see it literally
and I feel sorry for those Jawas but it
was so but I was like do it again do it
again the Jawas had like the worst
brunch ever that I was like what I
thought there was gonna be something so
cool in the egg it was like macking
matches or someday I think the Kamino
patch is still my top because I didn't
know that and then I think it was a
Reddit user that first found it and I'm
like you're right and that could change
everything and I freaked out but also
just seeing the Jawas get so much screen
time because that was always just like a
very visually pleasing character I liked
you
there's two and they're they're cute and
I like the noises they make but oh my
god we only got like a genious little
taste of them and now all of a sudden in
this one episode we see you know the
inner workings of the sandcrawler so
many little features that we never knew
before and like yeah laughs at the egg
thing but that was clearly something
that was very important to this epic
Star Wars race that we never really knew
before so the fact that this series is
giving us a little time to live with not
just the mando but others as well yes I
want more of that I know I looked at use
of Carbonite I was saying that in Empire
i watch that as a child and it terrified
me the use of Carbonite freezing and the
fact that they brought that back I
thought in the first episode and yeah to
me that was just sort of like all that
Star Wars nostalgia it was like a little
extra and and I can't wait to see how
they're gonna use it moving forward I
know I love the frozen carbon dioxide
there's no better time than to be a Star
Wars fan but is Star Wars fatigue a real
thing it's not for a lot of people
because I think there's still general
audience it's just like taking it as
part of an entertainment buffet I think
it that there's some truth to that a
little bit but I mean I got Star Wars
pins on my jacket like I'm okay
but I'm not the general audience so I
don't know maybe I'm not the general
audience either but I don't feel it in
the least and I'm someone who is going
out and watching the movies watching the
shows watching the animated series I
read a lot of the books I loved it and I
loved it because the world is so big yes
the Skywalker's have been our main focus
for a very very long time but there are
so many little corners that really now
at least on the the wider scale were
finally exploring I definitely highly
recommend people check out like the
comics and the books to find out those
little nuggets that they might not have
seen before I think that's what this
show is showing you is that there are so
many more nuggets to explore so rather
than being fatigued it makes me go oh
wait they could also go in this
direction or this direction I think
there's just even more now well guys we
are just barely I mean scratching the
surface here obviously we could go on
for hours and hours so hopefully we
answered some of your guys
questions if we didn't maybe join Bob
iger's masterclass maybe he'll answer
them but I can't have you leave without
giving me your fresh pick so these are
just shows on TV that you were watching
that you think people at home should
tune into all right are you ready yeah
it's weird okay I love watching British
gardening show yes
you need to watch love your garden with
Alan Tisch March over there in England
he goes to people in need and redoes
their garden and if you're not crying by
the time the sunflowers are growing
you're not a human and I watch that all
the time and then Monty dawn which is
like this he's this professor wears like
a cardigan and like boots and then he
goes in the yard and British gardens and
just it's I'm obsessed with it I was not
expecting to hear that for me where can
we find love your garden Netflix has a
run on it and the Monty Don stuff too I
have a question if you had to choose
between that and Star Wars what we all
need to love our garden that's our
planter that I won't be able to grow for
the life of me maybe I bought it it's a
great gift
yeah my pick is a youtube original show
it's impulse and it's basically the show
that they said was a spinoff from jumper
and yes it is to a degree but it's a
completely different set of characters
and it handles that bill that ability in
a very unique way but it's got one of
the best lead performances I've seen in
a new show in years her name is Maddy
Hassan she is phenomenal in it so it is
a show with a super cool supernatural
ability but what makes that come out of
her and her realize she's capable of
doing that is a very traumatizing
experience it's a very dark show and she
handles that emotion so so well I think
she is going to be one of the next best
things but until she gets more and more
opportunities I think impulse is well
worth the watch it's a great show across
the board and on YouTube yes on you
thing thanks Harry Nikki what do you
think mine's as much of a Star Wars
departure as British gardening is I
chose Dickenson which is on Apple TV
Hailee Steinfeld I think did a great job
in bumblebee she's the lead and it's the
story of Emily Dickinson but it told it
in a very very modern way and with
modern themes and it's one of those
there's ten episodes and it's just binge
it's just easy to pinch like I found
myself on episode 10 before anyone going
out how did that happen it's very
digestible yeah and I love that all ten
episodes are out for that one yes yes
well since we're talking about the
Mandalorian on Disney Plus I am obsessed
with the world according to Jeff
Goldblum I can watch this man do
anything the first episode is about
sneakers he dives into the world of
sneakers and I love sneakers but there's
a part in the episode where he just
plays street basketball with these
basketball players and I feel like I'm
watching my dad try and go at it and it
is just worth the money of Disney Plus
alone to watch Jeff Goldblum try and
play I heard somebody say you don't know
anything about sneakers but it's
fascinating to watch Jeff Goldblum be
fascinated about sneakers exactly the
whole time he's just like wow wow wow
there's like a weird funny deal that
goes done at that sneaker convention
he's at any con yeah yeah and just
witnessing it it's one of the weirdest
wonderful things yeah I've been there
buying the kicks alright guys well that
is our show I can't thank you guys so
much thanks to Ken and Perry and Mickey
for joining me today for more on the
mandalorian head on over to Rotten
Tomatoes comm and comment below and let
us know what you think about this series
so far also don't forget to hit that
subscribe button and notification about
so you don't miss any future couch
tomato episodes next time we'll be
talking about Apple TV plus so we'll be
diving deep in the Dickenson and all the
other shows I'm Nazz Prez and I'll see
you guys next time
[Music]